so let's compute the two-dimensional
curl of a vector field and the one i
have in mind we'll have an x component
of let's see not nine but y cubed minus
nine times y
and then the y component will be x cubed
minus nine times x
and you can kind of see i'm just a
sucker for symmetry when i choose
examples and i showed in the last video
how the two-dimensional curl the 2d curl
of a vector field
of a vector field v which is a function
of x and y
is equal to
the partial derivative of q that second
component
with respect to x
minus
the partial derivative of p that first
component
with respect to y
and i went through the reasoning for why
this is true but just real quick kind of
the in the nutshell here this partial q
partial x is because if as you move from
left to right vectors tend to go from
having a small or even negative y
component to a positive y component that
corresponds to counterclockwise rotation
and similarly this dpdy
is because if vectors as you move up and
down as you kind of increase the y value
go from being positive to zero to
negative or if they're decreasing that
also corresponds to counterclockwise
rotation so taking the negative of that
will tell you whether or not changes in
the y direction around your point
correspond with counterclockwise
rotation so in this particular case when
we start evaluating that we start by
looking at partial of q with respect to
x so we're looking at the second
component and taking its partial
derivative with respect to x and in this
case nothing but x's show up so it's
just like taking its derivative and
you'll get 3
x squared
minus
minus 9 there 3x squared minus 9. and
that's that's the first part and then we
subtract off
whatever the partial derivative of p
with respect to y is so we go up here
and it's entirely in terms of y and can
undo the symmetry we're just taking the
same calculation three y squared that
derivative of y cubed minus nine
so this right here is our two
dimensional
curl and let's go ahead and interpret
what this means and in fact this vector
field that i showed you is exactly the
one that i used when i was kind of
animating the intuition behind curl to
start off with where i had these
specific parts where there's positive
curl here and here but negative curl up
in these clockwise rotating areas so we
can actually see why that's the case
here and why i chose this specific
function for something that'll have lots
of good curl examples because if we look
over in that region where there should
be positive curl that's where x is equal
to 3 and y is equal to 0.
so i go over here and say if x is equal
to 3
and y is equal to 0
this whole formula becomes let's see 3
times 3 squared so
3 times
3 squared minus 9
minus 9 and then minus
the quantity now we're plugging in y
here so that's 3 times y squared is just
0 because y is equal to 0 minus 9
minus 9. and so this part is 27 now
that's 3 times 9 is 27 minus 9 gives us
18
and then we're subtracting off a
negative 9 so that's actually plus 9 so
this whole thing is 27 it's actually
quite positive so this is a positive
number and that's why when we go over
here and we're looking at the fluid flow
you have a counterclockwise rotation in
that region
whereas let's say that we did all of
this but instead of x equals 3 and y
equals 0 we looked at
x is equal to 0 and y
is equal to 3.
okay
so in that case
we would instead so x equals 0 y equals
3. let's take a look at where that is
x is 0 and then why the tick marks here
are each one-half so y equals 3 is right
here it's in that that clockwise
rotation area so if i kind of play this
we've got the clockwise rotation we're
expecting a negative value and let's see
if that's what we get we go over here
and i'm going to evaluate this whole
function again
by plugging in
0 for x so this is 3 times 0
times
0
minus 9
and then we're subtracting off
3 times y squared so that's 3 times 3
squared
3 squared minus 9
and this whole part is 0 minus 9 so that
becomes negative 9 and over here we're
subtracting off
9 minus
27 minus 9 which is 18 so we're
subtracting off
18
so the whole thing equals negative 27.
so maybe i should say equals that that
equals negative 27. so because this is
negative that's what corresponds to the
the uh clockwise rotation that we have
going on in that region and if you went
and you plugged in a bunch of different
points like you can perhaps see how if
you plug in 0 for x and 0 for y those 9s
cancel out which is why over here
there's no general rotation around the
origin when x and y are both equal to 0
and you can understand that every single
point and the general rotation around
every single point just by taking this
formula that we found for 2d curl
and plugging in the corresponding values
of x and y so it's actually a very
powerful tool because you would think
that you would think that's a very
complicated thing to figure out right
that if i give you this pretty
complicated fluid flow and say hey i
want you to figure out a number that
will tell me the general direction and
strength of rotation around each point
that's a lot of information so it's nice
just to have a small compact formula